Rapstar ASAP Rocky is back in Los
Angeles this morning
rocky and two other American suspects
were temporarily freed from a Swedish
jail until a Stockholm Court issues a
verdict in their assault trial the case
has received international attention due
in part to president Trump making an
appeal for rocky mt as ty Abbas in
Stockholm this morning MT as good
morning good morning yeah well ASAP
Rocky's release was a pretty unexpected
turn of events in what was already an
extraordinary case involving the leaders
of the United States and Sweden but the
rapper's legal troubles aren't over yet
ASAP rocky was all smiles after he
slipped out of a Stockholm District
Court taking to Instagram to thank his
fans for their support from the bottom
of his heart his family including his
mother were met by a massive media crush
outside the courthouse following a
judge's ruling the grammy-nominated
rapper and his two American co-accused
who've been in jail for a month could be
released while they await a verdict in
their case ambassador Robert O Brien
the u.s. is top envoy of hostage affairs
whose job is normally to help free US
citizens in war zones was in Sweden
monitoring the trial on the orders of
President Trump I just got off the phone
with presidents and let him know that
the men were coming home with the
president soon tweeting it was a rocky
week get home ASAP ASAP you could have
predicted this June 30th street brawl
would escalate into a diplomatic
incident involving the governments of
the United States and Sweden look just
for the cameras we don't want no
problems
go in the multi-platinum rapper whose
real name is Rakim mayor's was jailed
for allegedly assaulting a 19 year old
man several celebrities voiced their
support attracting the attention of the
president he got on the phone to
Sweden's prime minister asking for
Rocky's release a request that caught
the Swedish government and its ports
off-guard
I think it's a it's actually a very good
night for the United States of America
and for the kingdom of Sweden ASAP rocky
may no longer be in prison but he won't
find out if he's been convicted of
assault until August the 14th a
conviction which could see him put back
behind bars for up to six months for CBS
this morning Saturday
MPs tyub stucco